because i have a whole bit about that i
talk about how english is functional
it's effective yeah but french is like
sexy but unnecessary it's sexy to be
this it's sexy to some people that
romanticize it absolutely
listen you know me i'm not the biggest
fan in french no i'm not and french
quebec doesn't count your french like is
never sexy your french is just like uh
you know it's like why are you thinking
it's effective for like talking [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
quebec quebec quebec france
but i don't want it in the bedroom no
right
right oh the phone's my blood that's it
will never that's it that's nasty okay
it is yeah but sometimes nasty is good
you know but even english i find like
english dirty top nasty because i want
like a little [ __ ] daddy
that's nasty but that's very functional
i know exactly what's going on yeah but
if a girl comes up to you she's like ooh
my little croissant i was like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] what you calling me
he called me a little queso
right that's fire don't even lie that's
fire oh default smash shot
where's your cat at me where's your
it's way better
it is that's just listen i i've been in
each situation with each link meow [ __ ]
yes english gnostics
french
[ __ ] yo this sometimes i mean i'll be
with a girl right she's like speak to me
in french i'll be talking [ __ ] there she
don't know though
oh [ __ ]
they come
oh my
[Laughter]
all this to say i highly recommend that
you guys learn different languages if
you have the opportunity it's never too
late to learn trust me i've taken
language classes to brush up on haitian
creole i learned that in class i learned
the basics for brazilian portuguese and
the class have people of all ages
progressing and getting better so it's
never too late for you guys even if
you're american only speaks one language
you feel basic news flash you absolutely
are basic right like you are the bottom
of the totem pole but
you can grow and you can this video was
not about that it is now it is now it is
now we made it let me talk about
languages
i think we both have an appreciation
definitely right i speak four how many
you speak i don't know [ __ ]
how many did you properly speak okay uh
french
english yes patois
you should be here like proper yeah okay
but it depends because in jamaica
there's seven types of patwas okay which
three um understand and be comfortable
with okay when you get to four five six
seven like i don't know what the [ __ ]
you talking about okay you know what i
mean so
uh
uh creole right
so portuguese
but hold on hold on hold on let me get
in there yeah hey the portuguese i need
to practice because i'm losing it and
stuff like that so now i'm regaining it
because i'm practicing more and more and
more so i feel like it's there it's
crazy like i i like you like you [ __ ] is
dusty yeah but it's there and i've been
having conversations with people like
it's
i understand more than i thought right
and the spanish my spanish is very
[ __ ] basic yeah so various basics so
i wouldn't even count it as a language
that i can actually talk right so i'd
say five okay
and what do you think are some of the
benefits
of being able to speak all these
languages from your perspective like i
told you about that if you didn't know
if you didn't watch the documentary that
we have we still have the documentary
and i talk about it it's like you have
you're documentary is the one where
priest goes back to haiti for the first
time and basically spends time in this
midland so if you guys want to check
that out it's really good it's super
well shot we'll put the link we'll put
the link below it'll be in the
description so the thing that happened
is that you know it's always been my
life i didn't know who i was but i had
to take less space than possible just i
had to fit in you know i mean so it
helps you fit in
every situation that happens you're able
to connect with people that's though i
travel i'm in miami there's latinos i
see yo the guy's cuban i could go i
could i could throw a little egg
okay
oh [ __ ] right it takes a second there's
a connection this [ __ ] thought i
was like just a random right like hey
what's up how are you doing i'm good
or this time i pass i'm like i speak as
language you see the faces of people
light up so that's the thing no matter
like you can you can switch it up like
that you understand so that's the main
thing connecting with people is really
fast
it puts the guards down in people so you
can just chill and have a good time so
me when i go to miami i'm good i'm
surrounded with cubans
cubans everywhere yeah but because i'm
able to talk this and that it's dope
yeah all these things create links for
you to immediately feel closer to people
and so
if you like traveling for example your
experience traveling in a foreign
country when you don't speak the
language is completely different to when
you do
trust me when i go to haiti and i start
speaking a bit of crap people treat me
very differently than when they think
i'm blah blah you hear what i'm saying
the same token when i'm here in quebec
yeah people don't speak first right so
then they start talking to me in english
and i'm like and i'm speaking them in
their language i see them change the way
that they light up they're like oh it's
a connection that's made instantly right
there so
i like to travel i like to really get a
feel for how a country goes and
obviously we can't learn every language
so it's not feasible but if you have one
specific spot you want to go to maybe
it's a good idea to brush up on the
language and really learn it it'll bring
you some benefits the other thing too is
that learning different languages has a
weird way of making you more empathetic
to the people
because you understand why culturally
they're different it comes out in their
language too sometimes yeah i mean i
used to think haitians were loud turns
out yeah you guys are loud but the
language gives you a lot of energy we're
not allowed
we revolutionized
you try to spit that
why does every word have an exclamation
point because sometimes you gotta say
things with exclamation yeah
there you go
and that was really cool for me to just
be able to do that with a lot of
different groups and so
yeah if you want to travel if you want
to understand people better learning
different languages definitely is a good
bridge to you and other people other
accents don't hurt either
so yeah anything else you want to add
you ever had like whenever you went to
haiti you know like a haitian
[ __ ] just say your name and
just laugh and just look at you and not
ah
[Laughter]
that's very haitian that is yeah i got
an uncle that does that he says my whole
[ __ ] government name and he just
laughs and shakes my hand and i'm like
yeah what's up
and he leaves and i'm like
okay
i remember the first time like when i
went to cuba and i was like okay so just
keep how do you say hi always say hola
no that's not what i'm asking everybody
around here says what's up you say
what's up cause you work here
you say hi cause you work here what do
you say when you're in the streets and
you say what's up and then here is all
the meaning
he's like
oh okay you talk about okay so when you
see someone you know
okay you're gonna say que hola ah like
that's like what's up to us okay okay
papa
okay and then you could say that you
know what i mean that's that's like a
que weta hola is like touristy that's
what i'm talking about bro okay
the rest of the trip i was saying those
two words
he was happy happy it was it was a it
was it was a whole dance it was it was
uh online online online online
okay that was him he was when he saw me
because the connection and that's that
thing that's what you want especially
when you're in that could save that
could actually save your life to have
that kind of connection i was gonna say
for safety purposes that's like one of
the biggest things it's i i can't tell
you how enjoyable it is when you meet a
group of people who are looking at you
and then you speak their language and
you just see them change it is
it
it's like bro i'm home in a weird way
you're not home really but you feel like
you're being welcomed absolutely that's
a great feeling absolutely that's a
great feeling i even see from my mom
my mom struggles with english and french
for example but sometimes i'll take her
to places or i'll see link up with
people and my mom speaks like
four languages right she speaks english
and french functionally but not super
well but i'll be speaking like this arab
dude sometimes and then we'll become
your singing and then my mom will speak
to him in arabic
this dude
i don't exist anymore
no it's your mom now
and they start going off and i'm just
sitting in the back like oh okay
i don't speak eric
no no i i i started the haram life way
early i decided no but you got some
words and you got some [ __ ] that you
know yeah i can be like hayawan i can
insult somebody
yeah everybody yeah yeah yeah yeah one's
a good one
yeah it's when they're like animals you
call me yeah yeah
but when the kids running around i used
to hear mom's hairline all the time oh
really yeah yeah
and i'm not like
insults in arabic feel amazing
yeah yeah
i remember
like was going crazy he gets out of his
gets out of his car i get out of his car
yeah arabic dude
he's a he's a sir yeah he's an older man
yeah and he's just trying
this and that guy you don't [ __ ] know
how to drive
go back and forth and i finished it with
a shot
he lost his [ __ ] cause now
i ain't sold you in your language
what's up yeah you're not in this job
you're not our cowboy show you're not a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're a charm you
understand what the [ __ ] it is yeah bro
what's up he he was like what yeah what
he's like yeah i went back in my car and
i saw him he lost he lost his [ __ ] yeah
yeah so it's wonderful when you want to
really really piss off someone there you
go so if you want to connect with people
and really touch them where it matters
oh you want to disconnect with them all
right this is the way to do it sorry
we're just walking through this video
guys to encourage you guys to do that
it's a lot of people been asking me
about like new languages go do it sign
up for class you have to lose broaden
your horizons i feel like with all of us
being indoors for so long don't you see
stuck also doing duolingo all the time
go take a class with people because
communicating with folks from that
culture will help you listen to the
music all that good stuff there's
classes being run in your city most
likely for some languages go learn it i
highly recommend it all right so that's
all i wanted to say um learn the
language eat the food wash the news yeah
yeah except some foods some countries
have [ __ ] foods but we'll get to that
another day
oh boy